Hope is not a plan.
In order to have a real plan,
there needs to be real rigor.
I'd like to approach
strategic thinking in this class
by giving you this toolkit
so you can confront
whatever decisions that you have to make.
In 2014,
DreamWorks
had a couple of movies not work out,
so we were showing some losses.
Our stock price was down a lot
and we tried to ask ourselves,
what is the best future for a business
like this?
And so when you're making strategic
decisions, it's very important
to understand the connection
between the decision you make
and the strategic outcome.
If you have a strategy,
that is your end goal.
The decision is your tactic.
I'm Mellody Hobson,
and this is MasterClass.